i think jake needs to be the enemy on a
card i think that he needs to be the
villain you know and i think that you
need to you need to want to see him get
beat up in the same way that people want
to see floyd get beat up so the best
case scenario for a jake is if he's
fighting somebody that's incredibly well
ksi yeah ksi or nate diaz
ksi in this country
like is like
nothing in america yeah like he is huge
he is loved and uh he's fighting soon
yeah yeah this guy swarms i have no idea
who the [ __ ] is that why not fight jake
right now we have we talked to him the
other day we had him on the pod the
other day he was [ __ ] phenomenal
great and and uh but it was one of those
things where it's like now jake's
canceled about and then you have a
canceled about this is a great
opportunity to do it
but then again he's been acting active
for a while jake's just taking high
level stuff like you know he's flatlined
ufc champions
and jj has never never quite hit that
level yet because he only fought logan
then took a big break for his music yeah
but that's that that fight right that'll
do like
we'll sell wembley out when that happens
like it'll be
like anthony joshua level fight it'll be
[ __ ] massive yeah
this all started from a couple of little
youtubers
just pissed
here's the question i actually meant to
ask jay did this but then i we got
caught up just having fun
how many guys have done more for boxing
than ksi in the past 30
years it sounds crazy yeah but in terms
of just like bringing a lot of money
into it and then now
fighting for fighter pay and
like better care for fighters all this
stuff happened off of a couple of
youtubers ksi forget the other guy's
name being like hey let's box
that's what turned this whole thing it
really changed everything mate it's so
it's so bizarre but i never thought to
be honest with you when it all started i
was interviewing these guys right before
they had their first ever fight and i
never thought they'd actually fight real
boxers yeah yeah like and a lot of
people now were like yeah but he was a
ufc guy i'm like this guy started
punching three years ago yeah he's just
knocked out the welterweight champion of
the world in the ufc
like if we'd said that when that was
being when these guys were having their
first fights and not looking great
people had said you were full of [ __ ] so
i don't i think that people are people
just adjust to the now very quickly like
like obviously you're saying
logan oh he didn't win any rounds
against floyd i'm like listen to what
we're saying here
a white guy with no boxing experience
took three rounds off of the greatest
black
boxer ever but also happens to be black
that really is a blow to
the fact that white people can't fight
yeah right because that's something
people can't fight alex thinks he might
be able to beat you up i think he's
thinking
he's always loved the white guy versus
the black guy theme that's why he
those are the highest grossing fights
always you think if conor's black he
doesn't take the fight
uh yeah i agree i think it it needed
that element and it because floyd's a
businessman he understands what it
triggers people on a level as much as
the average guy doesn't give i i don't
know i i think maybe the average guy
does get invested by that i don't know
but i don't yeah i think there's
multiple story lines i think with boxing
specifically or fight sports
specifically you need like fan base it's
almost like uh football or soccer you
need like the entrenched fan base yeah
it needs to be tribal and i think that's
why the biggest fights now are like
mexico versus philippines yeah do you
don't think uh
to be the champion so [ __ ] badly i
can't even explain it and he's pakistani
yeah he's english but
i wanted him to be champion he's so
[ __ ] bad yeah it was unbelievable he
you would root for manny pacquiao
because he was closer to india because
he's asian we'll continue to do
so at the end of something
day yeah
yeah what am i going to do
podcast fight he's going to hold that
[ __ ] 35 man [ __ ] that
i i i train but i'm not like
my ego isn't there anymore do you know
when these young 20-something lads are
like looking at each other i'm like i
don't give a [ __ ] if you could beat me
up anyway like i don't
even
it's just fun for me well success
definitely satisfies that part of the
ego if you were 22 would you have done
it yeah absolutely i would have been
challenged in every [ __ ] my ego back
then was so different to what it is now
now when people talk [ __ ] about me on
the internet i'm like cool okay then
yeah i don't know
because it's different if someone's in
your face talking [ __ ] to you yeah
that's one thing yeah but if someone's
talking [ __ ] on their youtube channel i
know they're just doing it for the views
and all that yeah so i'm like i don't i
know they want a response from me so i
can help build their that was why when
logan bit i was like got him yeah
[ __ ] yes
but
i'm now happy where i am yeah i mean i'm
not bothered about any of that i've
heard you say you have a chip on your
shoulder do you still have that and if
so how do you reconcile that with okay
but i'm still not going to get affected
by this internet [ __ ]
uh i've got a chip on my shoulder about
getting like respected as a content
creator yeah that sort of [ __ ] like um
i guess like a comedian would when you
know when you feel like you're the guy
as a comedian you want people to
recognize that it makes you better at
what you do it makes you
put that time and energy and that the
next guy isn't doing so i think that's a
healthy way to have your ego make you
work harder but it's when people trick
you into doing dumb [ __ ] that your ego
is not under control
like me agreeing to fight [ __ ] the
heavyweight champion of the world or
some dumb [ __ ] like that you know i mean
i don't know like that i think that's
what we say with some of these young
guys is they get in the ring and before
they know they're like [ __ ] i don't know
a [ __ ] box yeah paul [ __ ] does and
all of a sudden he's knocking out nate
robinson because nate robinson is
looking at him going i'm an athlete
jake's like cool yeah good for you all
right man we'll see how that works out
for you yeah yeah you know i think that
ksi jake paul fight is kind of
inevitable at this point if you had to
make a prediction on that what would you
say right now
jake paul is the better boxer
but
i think jake and jj mentally
are very similar they're both evil
[ __ ] they both have that like
dogs that nastiness in them they both
want to hurt people they both take
enjoyment out of knocking other people
out like that so i think that by the
time that's why jj is taking his time to
get there by the time it happens
i think they almost the same height same
size same reach same so it's going to be
really interesting
because
they're both like kings of their own
sides of the uh the globe and all that
so it's very hard it's like a flip of a
coin at that point there's a uh you know
we were talking to jake and uh
jake seems concerned
about fighting a quote-unquote real
boxer yeah that's ego and that's ego oh
yeah and i said to him i was like [ __ ]
what these people think [ __ ] them if
you're going in there you're risking
your life make the big money fights
fighting
fight nate fight jj yeah but just who
cares what the average person is trying
to discredit you think because no matter
what you do they're going to discredit
you
classic example no one would have
thought you'd even get in the ring with
them he flatlined them
he's an emergency
yeah
even now he doesn't get respect really
but it's always something yeah he
thought he fought manny pacquiao that's
what they were all saying then oh yeah
you fought him too late it's always
going to be something people don't want
to like you they're not going to like
you they're going to find it another 50
million fighting this year and live
protect your brain yeah check the ego